voilà donc pour l'instant on était
visiblement à la pldoirie de l'avocat
vous l'avez vu beaucoup d'images arrêté
comme nous disons dans notre jargon cela
signifie que le procès a été monté comme
on dit beaucoup d'images arrêtées sans
doute pour ne pas montrer les membres du
tribunal qui ont condamné et fait
exécuter surcou je propose maintenant
comme ce procès la diffusion du moins a
commencé il y a une vingtaine de minutes
de prendre tout de suite connaissance de
des premières paroles de ce procès avec
ellisabeth
kilan le tribunal militaire est orchant
l'unique caméra filme les deux inculpés
Nicola et Elena tochescu jamais leur
juge l'homme qui fait office de
procureur les accuse de graves CRIM
d'actes incompatibles avec la dignité
humaine et demande leur condamnation à
mort à cet acte d'accusation chescou dit
qu'il refuse de répondre ailleurs que
devant l'Assemblée nationale c'est un
late motive on lui demande qui est
responsable de la situation désastreuse
du pays qui a donné l'ordre de tirer à
Timy choaror qui a fait tirer sur la
foule place du Palais
inoc qui a pay les mercenair étrang qui
Bent contre les
r répte Je ne répondraicune question SAF
devant l'Assemblé nationale et les
représentants de la classe ouvrière que
le monde ment devant ce coup d'État je
ne répondrai
pas